We all remember the help Tarkus gave us that day...
Tarkus was like us: someone trying to make it through the world
to uncover the truth.
The least we can do is follow in his footsteps and succeed where he failed.
The knights of Berenike are known for their heavy armor and weaponry.
There is no nation that is physically stronger.
But even among them,
There was Tarkus.
A knight renowned for having strength great enough to sport
a set of heavy black iron
that was unique to him alone.
Berenike was a land outside of Lordran
but it was not free from the curse of the undead.
As the curse spread and society crumbled countless knights became undead.
But the knights had not lost their sanity yet.
Throughout the neighboring lands, a prophecy was spreading.
An old saying from Astora that said this:
"Thou who art Undead, art chosen...
In thine exodus from the Undead Asylum, maketh pilgrimage to the land of Ancient Lords...
When thou ringeth the Bell of Awakening,
the fate of the Undead thou shalt know..."
The fate of the undead.
With nothing else to go on, the undead knights of Berenike ventured to Lordran
which was told to be at the heart of the undead curse.
They were right.
The Gods were partly responsible for the crumbling world.
The light in Anor Londo is an illusion and many gods have already abandoned
the world of men.
For the real light, the First Flame,
was fading.
There was one path into Anor Londo and that was through Sen's fortress.
So the knights of Berenike threw themselves at the deadly castle trying
to force their way through.
And they were not the only ones.
Within Sen's fortress we see the hollowed forms of both knights of Berenike
and Balder.
Two nations that attempted to reach the land of the gods. Desperate to discover
the fate of the undead.
Near the top of Sen's fortress there's an undead man who desperately tries to
retain his sanity.
Remember... counts... count, yeah... count! Counts
counts number one... one, two, three, fff...
four, four four fff..
ffive, five fivesix, seven! Count! Arghh.. Hrmmm!!
I can't... Hrrgggggggg!!
He has seen all the heroes pass through Sen's fortress never to return.
"For a century, they have tried,
and failed. The Knight King Rendal, Black Iron Tarkus, and even Logan himself.
You won't stand a chance. You'll be eaten alive. But,
go along, if you wish.
If only to deepen your despair."
They all failed.
Every knight of Berenike, every Balder knight,
the Knight King Rendal and Logan himself.
Every one of them failed...
Except Tarkus.
Tarkus conquers the fortress, leaving his hollowed brothers behind.
He carves his summoning sign at the top of Sen's fortress so his spirit will be
able to aid anyone else who comes as far as he does.
Time is convoluted in Lordran and even if Tarkus is already dead, his spirit will
remain to aid those who need help with the final step
even if those heroes exist in another dimension.
Fore guarding the final step to Anor Londo is the Iron Golem.
It is said that the soul of this construct was originally the bone of an
Everlasting Dragon
and it has slain countless heroes seeking Anor Londo.
For the sake of all those who came before him Tarkus prevails.
He becomes the first one to make it to Anor Londo.
But the tragedy begins here.
For when Tarkus arrives at Anor Londo he finds the path retracted before him
He must break into the palace by the only path available :
up a narrow ledge, through a window and across the ceiling rafters protected by
Painting Guardians.
This operation runs counter to his skills,
encumbered by his armor and huge weaponry Tarkus falls to his death on the rafters
and is dragged into a corner by the Painting Guardians.
But his death was not in vain because now the path is clear and Tarkus
helped you there.
For the sake of the fallen we carry on.